nettoyage désinfection il n'est pas
encore deezer france miniature s'éveille
avant d'accueillir ses premiers
visiteurs marily diakota y est hôtesse
d'accueil polyvalente c'est sa quatrième
saison sur le site élan courtois avec le
co vite ça un peu compliqué ce n'était
pas évident mais comme je suis une
ancienne
ils ont préféré aussi me reprendre et
parce que j'avais beaucoup plus
d'expérience dans l'entreprise en lui
même j'ai eu d'autres propositions
ailleurs mais on m'a proposé ici est du
coup bah j'ai préféré revenir ici france
miniature emplois à l'année 17 permanent
étudiants habitués les saisonniers sont
eux près d'une quarantaine la différents
métiers parce que rp un établissement
recevant du public comme le nôtre
regroupe différents commerces métiers
des restaurants boutiques
donc c'est que pour couvrir tous ses
aspects donc à la fois la partie muséale
du parc mais également les attractions
puisqu'on a également des attractions
pour les enfants et familles la
direction a connu un recrutement plus
compliqué cette saison fabrice la loure
a vu certains employés accepter d'autres
postes dans des secteurs où l'activité a
repris plus tôt
la difficulté lors de recrutements cette
année a été et est surtout lié à
l'incertitude de notre pas les nôtres
recrutement était total et complet au
moins de mars dernier avec une prévision
d'ouvertures pour le début avril
et c'est vrai que le fait de faire
attendre nos saisonniers ne sachant pas
notre couverture on a une déperdition
bien légitime
ils sont allés trouver d'autres métiers
ailleurs trois postes sont encore à
pourvoir à l'accueil aux attractions et
dans le management france miniature est
ouvert jusqu'au vacances de la toussaint